well
[Music
] greets you and allows you with places for
today thursday october 8 the supreme court
of nevada launched a lawsuit challenging
the law that contributes to voting by
mail in our state this is part
of an electoral initiative they acquire
with the arch the ballots  they are being
distributed starting this week and
must arrive before October 17
to review the important dates
regarding the November elections you
can visit our page and
diagonal dotcom illusion in Spanish
and today another of the neighbors reopens its
doors have registered  las vegas its
about planet hollywood like many
other resorts this one closed in march due
to the pandemic
elmer como sap it opened in june but the
hotel and casino remained closed until
now after this reopening the
cromwell property will be the only resort
still closed in  the street
and on the other hand the research world that
would be 8 months away from opening but
starting this weekend the hotel
looking to hire over 6000 employees they
will have a job fair on saturday
from 9 am to noon
if you are interested you can go to be bildu
located near the train and for street and
freeman suite and now we go to
the weather forecast today we will have a
maximum of 94 degrees with some views
in the valley however from the
weekend we will maintain
temperatures around 80 prepare
your coats because the cold is coming
also soon have a nice day and take care of
yourself I am Héctor Mejía and this was
your  informative creed of taught in
Spanish
[Music]